this baby ape has just been rescued and
is on her way to jungle school she is
one of many Bornean orangutans have been
orphaned by increasing deforestation the
cause a booming palm oil industry
evidence can endure him Navy team spot
sabatelli Efimova Elena's via [ __ ]
Parvati Pamela Elias J mrs. Nagi beat
him Navy's nomination rajim Tamia Oh
message a home production Abuja
homonymous passivity compras fear me
party agree open our openness liturgy
barely used some 30 years ago
palm oil can now be found in a variety
of products like margarine chocolate
spread crisps but also cosmetics
detergent and biofuel which accounts for
half of all imported palm oil and demand
is likely to rise unless the EU does
something about it navamsa shabeeha mom
nearly beat the Cubs keep our momentum
an ambitious initiative it's a Ameri
become community rebuild Pardo bill
police Parma viola in Apache homina
homina may observe a missile attack Oh
Bobby Oh Paula vikarna Buddha liquid
oversea botella he very versatile EU
lawmakers set a cap on crop based
biofuels in 2015 but the parliaments
Environment Committee is pushing for a
bolder faster response up for debate is
how fast palm oil can be phased out
[Music]